la validation emporte elle bientôt la
station de ski qui pourrait la sauver de
la désertification
un projet est en effet en cours d'étude
le sivom le syndicat intercommunal s'est
prononcé en faveur de la construction
d'un village de vacances près des pistes
de ski de fond du somport reste
maintenant le feu vert du ministère de
l'environnement dont l'avis est attendu
pour janvier prochain
le reportage d' olivier de marliave et
de phillippe reese la vallée d'aspe se
transforme petit à petit en mouroir la
moyenne d'âge de ses habitants baisse
chaque année davantage les jeunes
partent les maisons se ferment plus de
la moitié d'entre elles ne reprennent
vie que pendant les vacances et il y
avait en as trois fois plus d'habitants
après la dernière guerre qu'aujourd'hui
cette désertification tous bien sûr
toutes les pyrénées
lorsqu'il n'ya ni industrie ni stations
de ski et oui le seul point d'animation
en aspe c'est en effet payera maire et
ses boucles de ski de fond un splendide
ensemble de 40 km de pistes à la
frontière de l'aragon et qui attire de
plus en plus d'amateurs
à l'unanimité les élus de la vallée se
sont prononcés pour la construction d'un
village
de vacances au somport près de ces
pistes village qui devrait servir d'un
pôle d'attraction pour une économie du
loisir il nous faut une locomotive les
vallées voisines nous ont démontré ce
qu'un équipement l'altitude pouvait
apporter au reste de la vallée il n'y a
pas dans cette vallée pour l'instant de
dynamique
il n'y a pas eu lieu où il se passe
quelque chose qui servent d'exemple un
lieu qui soit un lieu de vie un dieu
d'atteindre d'attraction il nous le faut
est ce que le ski le fonds sera
suffisant on va le dire ce qu'ils nous
disent qu'ils font une activité nouvelle
qui se développe très rapidement mais il
semble que nous ayons la rue un projet
très intéressant dans la mesure où nous
puissions compléter l'activité ski de
fond par une activité ski alpin avec la
jonction du sommet de cannes du show et
un projet qui serait un projet encore
espagnols stations dans les pyrénées
franco espagnole basée sur le ski de
fond et le ski alpin une grande station
internationale entre l'aragon et le
béarn pourquoi pas les centres de
candanchu et d'aston situé juste à la
frontière sont fréquentés à la saison
d'hiver par quelques 80 mille skieurs
espagnols et ces deux stations en manque
de capacité d'accueil un village où son
corps pourrait donc servir de complément
lié bien sûr à l'entrée d'un grand
centre de ski de fond et de piste mon
opinion c'est très favorable parce que
moi comme responsable administration s
qui en a pas à l'exportation et tendre
et les situations de réalisation de
cette station
on a principalement déficit et d'accueil
c'est à dire on a trop affaibli pour la
capacité de du domaine skiable
et à part ça moi j'ai déjà commencé il
ya plusieurs années avec lé maire
d'urdos monsieur père de faure une
collaboration pratiques pour favoriser
professionnels et ski de la vallée
d'aspe pour que les français qui sont
des ses côtés moi je considère de la
région pirmin lang français que
d'espagnols il vient faire des skis ici
avec la même facilité qui ont des sexes
et de la vallée d'art de l'arabe en
espagne
reste que le fond de la vallée d'aspe
fait partie du parc national des
pyrénées y construire un village de
vacances supposerait donc un
déclassement de cette zone
l'étude qui est en cours sur le projet
permettra au ministère de
l'environnement de se prononcer au début
de l'année prochaine